last card down and dirty
king's bet dollar i'm in
in i'll see the dollar
and raise it five
you raised five dollars on that i called
goggle
queens full of nines
hey kid don't you know what a full house
is yeah and i also know what a psych out
is
i love this boy
my mom and dad are splitting up yeah
looks that way
you're lucky when i was your age i could
only dream about my parents splitting up
your mom is my grandma yep
grandma says you're a bitter
disappointment
boy is your eye red
you should see it from in here
what are you doing here jake my mom
brought me
will you take me swimming in the ocean
can we talk about it after my head stops
exploding
why is your head exploding well
i drank a little too much wine last
night if it makes you feel bad
why do you drink it nobody likes a wise
ass jake
you have to put a dollar in the sway jar
you said ass
tell you what here's 20. it should cover
me till
lunch
i think he's got you pal he's bluffing
he always pulls with you and he bluffs
goodbye the mighty mouse you win
take him down
call you i hate this kid
what the hell is going on here you said
hell
throw a dollar in the pot what hey we
all had to
what are you watching i'm watching a
movie
and you're not supposed to be watching
anything oh yeah
it's that guy a good guy or a bad guy
good guy
and you're not supposed to be watching
tv i know
is that his girlfriend ex-girlfriend
but he still loves her right i'm not
gonna walk you through the whole movie
i think so go to bed jake
okay
who's that guy that's the guy who's in
jail with and told him where the money
was hidden
all right hey you're being punished
no tv i know
what the hell is going on
jake so uh what else is new
mom's got new clothes and new hair it's
like she's a different person or
something
but she's still the same person jake no
not really
she walks around the house singing all
the time
she just sings for no reason i guess
i wonder if it's the same reason i sing
for no reason
does coach phil sing for no reason oh
for god's sake charlie
hey you want to go down in the arcade
and play some air hockey no
want to go to a movie no come on i'll
take you to something already
see some boobs leave me alone
are you mad at me what was your first
clue
well frankly your dismissive attitude
toward boobs
what are you doing we're eating dinner
he had dinner an hour ago well then he
won't need breakfast and i will
have you had enough to eat hey jake
you know what i like to do after a nice
big meal what
learn to dance
charlie yeah private word
sure
what's up shame on you is that it
you found that girl and now you have
some kind of depraved plan to use my son
as bait
yeah so it's not like he pays rent why
shouldn't he pitch in order
hello ellen you home candy
what are you doing here i thought i'd
surprise you with a booty call
dad lower your voice booty call
well it's
you know this is more the kind of thing
a a son should learn from his father
okay maybe you should ask him now
all right i'm going to hell
uncle charlie you awake
go away don't you want to be the first
one to wish me a happy birthday
jake i swear to god wait not yet
five four three two
one okay now get out
[Laughter]
you can give me your present now if you
want to
if you leave immediately i'll give you
the gift of life
all girls three french maids two
drunk twins and a lap dance in a pear
tree
merry christmas uncle charlie oh right
the other part of christmas
go ahead open it oh hold on let me give
you your gift first
don't want you to think i forgot you
a hundred bucks wow picked it out myself
it's not literally wheat it's the
sweetest breakfast treat
it's maple maple me delicious
you know who wrote that song your uncle
charlie wrote that no lie
kid if i was gonna lie i'd say i wrote
steroid of heaven not the maple loop
song
you two are really good together thank
you
so does your wife sing too oh no no i'm
not
married what a shame
wow you're even better than a dog
you